hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and I went
and saw a week late Shazam
I was deciding whether to do Shazam or
Hellboy this week and honestly I want to
do Hellboy more because I pretty much
missed Shazam
already last week by doing Pet Sematary
I think everyone and their mothers have
talked about this movie already and I
really love Hellboy and I'm hoping that
this is really great however didn't line
up with my schedule so we're doing
Shazam I was gonna see this regardless
of if I did an episode on it or not
because it's been just getting the best
reviews and I was really excited about
it I love hearing people praise DC I
love Marvel with all of my heart but DC
is like my og love that animated series
of the Justice League the DC ladies are
really cool and they've been showcased a
lot more than the Marvel ladies I'll say
and so yeah I love I love them both I
would say equally but I was really
excited to hear that a DC movie a DC
superhero film was doing really well
most really excited for detective
Pokemon detective Pikachu respective
Pokemon Hey okay she's aunt let's give
me this Chism I knew going in that it
was gonna be good it's got amazing
ratings on everything and everyone that
I've talked to has just loved its death
and seen it multiple times and that's so
exciting sometimes I think it's better
to go into a film not knowing anything
about it specifically like what others
are thinking about it because that
really shapes how I feel about a movie I
know that people are loving it I feel
like I need to love it kind of deal you
know I mean I don't know if people
really identify with that but I that is
how I really feel like I I need to stay
away from other people's opinions on
things especially movies because I get
nervous that I'm gonna say the wrong
thing just stupid because you're all
tuning in for my opinion that's dumb
Tamara I though I loved this movie it
was so cheesy in all the right ways it
was so engaging it was entertaining all
the way through
it was fun it was funny was heartfelt
the action was cool it ruled I love this
movie I wasn't expecting the amount of
cheese we got though I was expecting it
to be like kind of a sleek superhero
film and it wasn't that like the opening
shot of the Grand Wizard in his cool
little Grand Wizard temple was so cheesy
and a lot of it looks like okay here's
what I'll say I guess a lot of it in
like 20 years I think we're gonna look
back on it and be like that looks cheesy
as hell but I think in 20 years we're
also still gonna be really entertained
by it it's gonna hold up in that it's
just so well done and so fun so they
leaned into that cheese and I just love
it I love cheesy movies that are good I
didn't get what I was expecting but I
don't know what I was expecting I don't
know anything about Shazam Shazam is
like you know one of the lesser-known
I would say for I mean I don't know I
grew up with DC and I don't know much
about Shazam at all
and so I went in kind of expecting like
this sleek superhero with some comedy I
saw the trailers of course but I got
something way way way less sleek and way
more cheesy which I loved the cast sold
this thing so much I think I don't know
if it's just because it's the beginning
of the year but I feel like in a lot of
these Tamra just saw episodes recently
this beginning of this year I've been
saying things like oh I just didn't get
enough character development or I didn't
like get to know the characters that we
should have really gotten to know you
get in here and there's six foster kids
and you know all of them you know
everything you need to know about them
you get who they are as people you get
like a snippet of their background you
love them it's so easy to connect with
these characters and they spend barely
any time on it just enough so they don't
graze over it but you you don't get like
you're not sitting there for this whole
origin story you get in there you see
the kids you get to know him we're
moving on with their story and I love
that I felt so connected to all the
people the whole time I was watching the
film
and it made me love it so much more at
the end when they turn into their own
little Shazam's it was so good that
moment was amazing and I really was not
expecting that to happen I didn't know
that that was a thing Shazam could do
seeing all the adult actors who are
mimicking these children actors that
we've grown to love during the film was
so much fun - they did such a good job
with casting this just all over across
the board it's so well cast so good I
have loved the origin story for our
villain it's so messed up and so dark
and uncomfortable I feel so bad for this
little kid and then you don't because
he's a villain and that was there was
just a sentence
Wow I really like this set up with that
I love that you're back in time because
just a simple thing that he's got the
magic eight-ball kind of takes you back
you know you're not in today's current
time and his dad and brother assholes
and he gets so close to becoming the
next Shazam and then the Grand Wizard is
like oh well you'll never be good enough
you're not Shazam so cheesy and then the
dad almost dies and then resents him his
whole life and it's like a big president
businessman and it makes sense
it's like quick it's effective it's
funny it's and it's great I love it
that's what I want in a villain origin
story I also think they handle that all
really well because this is a character
that a lot of people don't know I'm a
firm believer that if you're making a
superhero film and you think that the
audience doesn't know everything about
that hero you don't need to baby step
them through it you can do it in a smart
way that you still get some origin of
course but it's so I say this a lot with
guardians of the galaxy I think no one
basically knew like no one in the
general populace knew the origin story
of guardians of the galaxy but they did
it in such a good way that it didn't
linger too long
it wasn't like baby stepping us through
this was similarly done I think it was
so so good
super fun super light and then it wasn't
light as well it was pretty messed up
but light in a way that wasn't just like
okay we get it can we just it's been two
hours I would like to see the actual
movie now it was done in such a good way
they have this giant montage of him
using his powers when he first finds out
that he's Shazam and it's such a good
sequence
he's button-mashing it played video game
cities button mashings like the Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat or one of
those that you button mash on and he's
just like got super speed so he can like
button mash the shit out of it and it's
so funny the don't stop me now mr.
Fahrenheit sequence in this movie is one
of the best sequences I've seen in a
film in years
it was so joyful so I I wasn't gonna
write notes and then I was like oh
there's too many good points I'm gonna
forget it I'm filming this tomorrow so I
started like typing notes on my phone
with my brightness all the way down like
a jerk you shouldn't have your phone out
of freakin films camera okay anyways he
wrote joyful so many times no I was just
having the best time with it
best cheesy so so cheesy but man I'm
cheese in myself that's the thing I
actually wrote ridiculous a group of
five foster kids turning into
superheroes all at once is a dream
joyful as hell Wow I wasn't really
feeling it our villain calling the
foster families home a diverse shithole
seemed intentional I loved that the
villain at the end is most closely tied
to Envy's about the seven deadly sins
around him helping him fight but envy is
the one I think that's really relatable
I don't know that's something that I
struggle with for sure so many of the
comments oh really not gluttony tamra
it's funny it's hilarious
oh there's some really deep shit with
like him in his actual mom that he's
trying to find and and and and the
foster family is so so so lovable and
maybe a little unbelievable and how like
wonderful that situation is was really
beautiful to see and I just loved it I
loved it so much I was really upset
because the the only showing I could go
to last night was at 9:45 and I don't
like seeing movies crazy late because
then I can't usually film when I get
home afterwards it's just too late I'm
an old woman
I'm 28 going on 57 usually I'm in bed
playing video games at that time gosh
darn it I was upset and I went in okay
fine let's just get through this it was
amazing of course obviously such a
curmudgeon about seeing films I loved it
it was amazing I'm really excited to see
how boy and I might do something on my
personal channel for that or if there's
nothing great coming out next weekend
maybe I'll do it
next weekend for Tamara just saw but I
wanted to catch up with this as well I'm
also very excited about Pokemon also
Dora the Explorer what I don't know what
to think but I will say this if Swiper
is not in that goddamn movie I'm walking
out I love when people say they're gonna
walk out of movies but you already
bought the tickets so no one's affected
by that except for you thank you so much
Reggie I will see you all next week I'm
back hey my name's Jo my powers may slow
through hey babe don't be Wendy
it's a beautiful okay money none of that
[Music]